going to see and you have to ask him
about his ping-pong tournament well tell
I wish you luck on your endeavors to the
heiner's and a very very warm welcome to
Juma
and sunny South Africa it is as sunny as
sunny can get it is bright it is breezy
and it is very pleasant to be out on a
game Drive now as television my name is
Justin on camera today I've got two
Darvey which is always an absolute
pleasure to have on board and well we
are going to be trying to see if we
can't catch up with Tandy and Cubs so
that is the plan for this afternoon
hopefully we will be able to get some
sort of luck with Tandy and cut this
afternoon we'll have to just try and see
now remember it is interactive so it
hashtag safari live on Twitter or the
YouTube chat if you want to get hold of
us now Taylor you were wondering about
our ping pong okay Taylor well our ping
pong was delightful Toby was it
delightful it was delightful now I've
got a video to show all of you for those
of you that don't know what we're
talking about today was the ping pong
Palooza challenge yeah at a Juma and so
what that entailed was basically the
following so I'm going to play you a
video and you will be able to see how
this all wings
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so that's is what happened today so tell
it was a very successful event and you
want to know who won well we had a team
competition to start which was the Black
team so Davi and I were on the Black
team with Kirsty and Rebecca and a few
others who else was an egg she was in
our team and Louise that's right so it
was three girls three boys and so the
six of us managed to beat the red team
but unfortunately the overall winner was
a member of the red team and that was
James Henry and I lost to him in the
final which is a disaster and you can
see there was much celebration after all
of that right well try to find Tandy and
Kutner after we worked up a sweat in our
ping pong challenge and while we do that
I think we don't - Noelle I'm not a
hundred percent sure but either way it
will be one of our members of the Safari
Live Crew for the afternoon it is a very
warm afternoon I'm so sorry to hear that
you lost two games with ping pong
Palooza I sadly was cracking the books
today for my practical examination so
I'm glad everyone had a good time how
amazing everyone was that sighting with
Brent's cheetah and that warthog
superjealous Brent I hope you get some
more action up there
I am Noelle and I'm Cameron to that
camera - I can't talk on camera today I
have the ville de B's VM hello
thumbs up so yeah we're just plodding
along and waiting for it to cool down a
little bit I'm actually in search for
Elephants I'd really like to see some
swimming elephants today so we're
checking biffle's hook Dam and then
we're gonna head down towards a chitwa
chitwa and see what we can find along
the way as you know Tristan's headed
over to see if he can find tun Dee and
her youngster and then we're hoping that
maybe husana pops up over on chitwa side
but you never know what might happen
also maybe shadow and her youngster
maybe come up by twins twin dem so we'll
go and have a look down there now
amazingly our hippo friend is not here
in biffle's hook damn I don't know where
he's gone or where he could be maybe he
has decided that he is too lonely and
needs to go and try and find some
females
or maybe on his feeding out and about
this after this last evening he managed
to find a place that just suited him a
bit better but I'm sure he'll be back in
a few days all right we're gonna go
check the corner because the other thing
I would like to see is maybe the wild
dogs they haven't been over to us for a
while and last time that we saw them
they moved over a bit east
so as we're busy searching we're gonna
send you all the way back up to Brent in
the Maasai Mara with his a cheetah's who
are still busy on their kill and I'll
let you enjoy the spectacular sighting
that that is
sorry about that everybody
Rimland attacking a Brent but he'll be
back with you shortly not to worry for
those of you that don't know who what a
ram Ellen is it's just a cute little
word that we use to describe some
technical issues that come with
forecasting and promote Africa but
anyways these things happen every now
and then we're driving through the
lovely golden grass at the moment but we
are edging closer and closer to Ward's
of the high uniden and we're not too far
from the River Road now basically where
the next line of trees is is essentially
where that highway is we'll jump on that
and that should take us to our
destination relatively quickly although
we've got a bit of time to spare what is
the time cut apart almost quarter past
five Eastern African time so yeah I'm
just trying to think it might take us
again the great thing about coming on a
safari is that you have a plan to go and
do one thing and it can easily change
because you know you've opted into
something that's even more amazing so
who knows they might see the mokoro
pride maybe we've come across Scarface
and his clan around McFadden's pride
speaking of hyenas not tennis you've
asked what animal do I think I'm most
like I find this Adam this question hard
to answer so I'm gonna let you'll answer
it for me everyone says my spirit animal
is a lion I think it's because I have
lots of pain but maybe you guys didn't
come up with something quite funny and
don't worry I don't get offended easy so
go wild hashtag safari live or chat to
us via the YouTube and what do you think
what animal do you think I'm most alike
now Megan who's directing this afternoon
is rescinded she thinks I'm like an
arena trogon because I'm most unique
Thank You Megan that's very kind of you
I showed Megan and marina trogon
yesterday when we went on a little
safari park or a little exercise and
hiked which was a lot of fun so it was
actually quite surprising we heard of
calling and then any and ended up being
right above us it was so beautiful in
the only patch of light in the forest -
and normally with marina trogon is that
they're quite shy birds and they tend to
hide themselves away and always turn
their backs - you see the green which
makes them very difficult to spotter
from the trees but we were so lucky I
said - Megan that's probably one of the
best sightings of an arena trogon I've
ever had I have a video but it's not
gonna do much for you unfortunately
because it was up in the trees above us
basically through a hole about that big
and all you could see was the bright red
of its braced and it was just cooking
down and I was watching us and we stood
for five or six minutes just in absolute
or admiring it so I don't know if I'm
quite as unique as a marina trogon
because there's something quite special
but thank you Megan that was very kind
of you here we have some water rock and
rock
well the giraffe sort of circling the
outskirts of the marsh the water buck
jumping straight into it let's have a
have a little look-see okay you said I'm
like a jackal is it because I for some
reason every time I see those jackal
pups they run up to my car so who me I
don't know why that is I don't know if
they'd do that to everybody if they're
just do it to me I like to think they
just do it to me it makes me feel a bit
better about myself and that's quite a
good one it might not be as quick as
them as good as catching grasshoppers oh
but I do try no the water back I'm not
worried about grasshoppers over there
waiting to eat them they are feeding on
all the lovely lush grass in the marsh
and this is how you should be seeing
water back you know missus I haven't
seen it for quite some time the last
time I'd see water back and in marshy
sort of areas or wetlands was in Zambia
and lower Zambezi National Park but we
typically don't see this and the sabi
sand unfortunately there aren't enough
areas
well they I don't think there are any
areas with his marshes I'm trying to
think
nope not that I could think of
everywhere that I've worked on in the
sense and quite have a marshy area so so
it is quite nice to see that again the
male has not lifted his head once now
this is quite interesting what I find it
quite fascinating I don't know if you
remember a few weeks ago we were seeing
two water buck and bulls in this area
this is the same spot that brains and I
like to do a lot of birding as often
when we see that malachite Kingfisher
just for context and we had two of them
having a standoff remember that morning
was beautiful in the golden light and
they were other male mutt this one when
I think was much older and he had much
bigger horns but he got chased away by
this young upstart and I think that
that's quite nice to see that sometimes
it's not always the biggest bull with
the longest horns I suppose it's all
about your technique in terms of
fighting and he must have won because
he's still here with the same group of
water buck that we see almost every
single morning that we pass through on
this River Road very very very nice
also the same herd that I pointed out to
you a couple of times I've said the
females are looking quite big now and
their bellies are bulging so hopefully
we'll start to see a few more youngsters
popping out but remember it will take a
wee week or two before they bring them
back to their herd because they'll give
birth off on their own and in thickets
so we probably won't see who might
actually see that see that's can't the
females one two three four five six
seven eight nine so I can see nine here
they're no more on the other side of the
road I didn't count how many new water
buck females were here the last time
that I saw them so let's say that maybe
one or two of them have already gone off
to give birth because there was
definitely one female that was very very
big right I'm going to send you as quick
as I can
down to the sabe sad because Noelle has
got an exceptional sighting of them
species of mongoose that i have not seen
for a very long time we just came across
this really cool slender Mongoose and he
was finishing up the tail end of what
looked like a lizard or a skinned kill
and now it seems as if he's sniffing
around trying to figure it out if
there's anything left for him to eat now
unfortunately we just got the tail end
of it and we're unable to put it on
camera for you but it looks as if he's
managing to find tiny little bits there
he was finishing it off just there where
he's smelling and now having a rest
licking his chops from his lovely little
meal Mongoose will eat snakes they're
very good at killing and eating snakes
they'll also eat termites and large
beetles and of course now as we've sort
of shown you the lizards as well now he
might stick around long enough to groom
and clean himself most species were most
organisms I searched they say after a
meal we'll do a bit of cleaning
especially if the meal was a larger one
just to make sure everything's still in
place we see it often with birds we see
it with lion and leopard but it's also
true of our our smaller mammals as well
there he's cleaning his paws off making
sure to get all the gunk
and it's interesting he's not too far
from us so he's I think he's just
checking to see what we're up to as well
every now and then just to make sure we
don't invade his space puzzle the
piss-face bubble I'm so sorry I'm
tripping over my words today everybody
I'll drink some more water just now that
will help as we're driving around the
breeze is even better but as we sit
still the heat is pretty intense and not
gonna lie
dries your mouth out also this is a good
sign because we don't usually get to see
slender mongoose often Catherine you're
saying how cute the slender Mongoose is
yes monkeys are well Mongoose are cute
definitely cute little species so
there's been a raging debate between
myself and a few friends about what are
we actually supposed to call a mongoose
is a mongoose mongooses hmong guy and
then we were chatting with a biologist
friend of ours and he was saying it's
just Mongoose but I do catch myself from
time sign saying monkeys would make
sense because you go from gusta geese
but it's just Mongoose all right
fantastic slender Mongoose finishing up
his kill there we've picked up on a
little bit of male leopard tracks in
building I have been debating about who
this male effort could be the tracks are
rather large both of us are sort of
hedging our bets towards ting gana but
the problem is these tracks are not very
fresh they're probably from last night
and there's another vehicle that's
driven on top of them but in general
he's heading down this road so another
reason why we're thinking in certain
Ghana is the fact that because he's
sticking to the road and he's going to
the inside curves and the way that he's
moving
this might actually turn let me just see
if I can find a nice little sequence up
here means that there's possibly some
scent-marking that's happening which
would mean that it wouldn't be something
like tompa tomba is too small for
scent-marking and also the tracks are
very large so as we know tomba has big
feet
but these feet are very big sorry I'm
just trying to see if I can find them
for you again
I had one back there but it wasn't the
best to show on camera no I've lost them
a little bit it's possible that he cut
around the curve here let me see as we
go along if I can find you on another
nice sequence
now on a hot day like today right now it
would be rare to find a leopard walking
around but that being said I have
friends that work in the pylons Berg
National Park which is farther west
north from us in South Africa and it's a
park that sees quite a lot of traffic
from private vehicles and something that
they found over the years they've been
working there there's a lot of the
leopard activity actually happens in the
middle of the day when the vehicles tend
to be resting and they tend to find
leopards hunting in 40 degrees Celsius
whether in the middle of the day sort of
1 o'clock 2 o'clock and it's an
interesting scenario so I don't know if
there's something else that plays up
with it there's also quite a large lion
population that's there there could be
other mitigating factors but my friends
at work they're convinced it has to do
with the amount of people that are
coming into the park now we've got a
beautiful kudu that's just up here
now unfortunately moving away and I
don't think we're gonna be able to get
too nice of a view I think Brits comms
have come back so let's head back up to
him in the Masai Mara and see what he
can show us with those cheetahs sorry
about all those gremlins with him but it
seems to sort itself out so you must
enjoy
well it's unfortunately when were a bit
closer to them and we couldn't care the
final control but they absolutely
smashed that little warthog in no time
whatsoever they ate it all up it's
pretty much dance keys now and I've been
trying to check with my binoculars for
the female she's probably made good her
escape
I might go look for a little later but
I'm pretty sure she would have jogged
but unfortunately for her if she keeps
in that direction she's gonna run into
me Olly
so me Olly was in the direction where
she started heading off with and the
boys started chasing this young warthog
and if you're a warthog it's a bad day
if you are a cheetah
it's a lovely Sunday Wow human
equivalent of a suckling pig I suppose
so good for the boys they'll be quite
happy with that although I don't think
it's gonna be enough to sate them I
think they might hunt again just now but
should keep them a little bit less
hungry for a little while
remember this is all a hundred percent
live coming to you from the masai mara
and the greater Kruger in South Africa
and in Kenya we are sitting in the Masai
Mara of course Tristan and Noelle are
sitting in the greater Kruger on Juma
and we've found our spotted cats well we
found eight different cheetah this
afternoon let's hope that Noelle and
Tristan can find you guys some leopards
and to finish off the big cat afternoon
because we have seen lions already so
lions and cheetah so we're relying on
Noelle interesting to find us some
leopards and Tristan no excuses today
okay not all of them would have got a
very good meal out of that oh it sounds
like we have a possible ID for the
female James Richard says that female
might have been Rosetta which is roses
daughter now I've never heard of either
of those two cheater so there we go
you learn something new every day now it
looks like some of the boys are up and
about already that little warthog did
not touch sides well some of them are
flopping down others are on the move now
you will see there are other vehicles
enjoying the sighting with us but you
can see still quite an empty belly a
little pig that doesn't go far when
there's five of you now guys I'd be
heading the other way there's a lot more
game where I came from then across the
side
now are you going to plunk or you going
to keep walking that is the question
I've got a feeling they might plunk for
a little bit well maybe not
wasn't a very long chase for them so
they wouldn't have utilized too much
energy catching that that little warthog
how's that for simultaneous sitting
choreographed it has plunk our bottoms
the exact same time now
d'Artagnan the greedyguts that he is is
the last to leave what is left of little
you
Lia's striding towards the others and
apologies we are right on the edge of
some of the signal we're really down low
in a in a river system
so hopefully the boys keep heading up up
up and away towards a better signal and
comms area they normally do it this time
in the day and they move out of the
low-lying areas up towards the crests
following the prey species which
normally do the same
and you can probably yeah it's quite
windy at the moment the next are you
what are you up to you going to plonk
yep plonk you never know what could
happen next
another poor unsuspecting warthog might
wonder towards them
we're gonna keep an eye on the boys for
now hopefully they do get moving
otherwise we do have plan B C and D now
me Ali the Lions and Rosetta possibly
want that o name so we're gonna see what
happens here for a bit longer before we
move on while we do that it sounds like
mccurdy is racing off somewhere just
trying to get to that hyena den and he
feels like it's getting further and
further away buttbrain she'll be happy
to know very very briefly you got to see
this
the straw tailed wider yeah you've been
telling me about in you for one on
screen the other day which is very cool
and we just passed it for fools sadly I
didn't get to show all of you but it was
really nice to find me see I've been
quite lucky with the birds this week in
terms of how many new ones have actually
added to the list which is really quite
cool that's supposed to go down
the next one the next hyena just
checking here for anymore birds the spot
is quite nice
although it's dried up quite a bit so
they mustn't have had too much rain here
last night a little bit it's a bit wait
but no one's home only there's a Goliath
heron that lives the only good stuff who
is a Goliath here and that's around here
no no birds not even the Egyptian geese
today that's unusual rumor we've seen
couple of times I've stopped sharing
this then whole flock Bless You Craig
bless you another one just two
now scenic you're wondering what species
of widow birds are found in Kenya shall
we have a look let's bring the book out
quickly have a look as I can rattle off
all so it takes me a while to stop I can
rattle off all sorts of names but I
think it would be better if we actually
took a look at them don't you think and
luckily widow bird should be right at
the end too when are we gonna start 686
600 and s are quite far am i here I here
feels like spider webs sometimes on my
face um almost promise we're almost
there right next page okay right so
theoretically the Yellow crowned no
that's a bishop that's all one branch
has been telling me about that I need to
keep an eye out on there not that one
here we go yellow a mint old widow bird
so number four down here on the bottom
right
I'm so sorry Krieger I can't even see my
monitor at the moment but that one they
were my thumb is that is one that we get
to see so we get quite a few down here
let me go to the next page yes these
look familiar then top left is the
fantail Twitter bird which i think is
the most common one that we're seeing at
the moment and the white winged widow
bird which is number two I've seen that
in South Africa yes we see that in the
greater Kruger area that's one that we
see quite often Mike it just occurs on
the border of Kenya and Tanzania and in
Tanzania so maybe we'll see it down on
the border route number three the red
colored widow bird we must certainly see
lots of them and then the yes so there
we go so one two three maybe a few more
species of of widow birds too but the
most common ones that we're seeing at
the moment on the red colored the fan
tailed oh and then where's the Jacksons
why can't I find Jackson's ah there's
another page of widow bird brained was
also telling me that I need to keep an
artful number two which is that one and
the Jacksons were a bird which I haven't
seen just yet so I'll keep an eye out
for the
I think he said he did I don't know if
he managed to put one on screen but I
know he was trying the other day I don't
think it was sitting still but very cool
so there's a variety of widower bird
species and that we get to see out here
in the Mara it was very nice
I think the only one that I haven't seen
so far is the Jacksons I really really
need to make an effort to go through my
Birds and figure out how many I've
actually seen over the years because
I've completely lost count I also don't
have my well now with my Kenyan Birds I
think I'm probably seeing quite a few
more birds since I've been here in the
Mara but for me it doesn't matter about
numbers it's just constantly learning
about the new Birds and seeing them one
day when I'm born I'll eventually go
through and count them or on a rainy day
right but I am gonna send you back
across the Mara River are we gonna go
from the triangle for the Masai Mara
National Reserve print is not leading
those cheetah out of his sight
well welcome back everyone we're still
sitting with their boys and as I
predicted they have plugged for now
doing a bit of grooming after their
little piggy afternoon rest
I say it's gonna be interesting to see
if they're handy and I'm not sure that
they're going to to be honest but you
never know and I think they are worth
spending the time with the slot so don't
look quite settled just yet there's
quite a bit of up-and-down movement
let's go across to the to grooming yeah
let's clean the blood off each other's
faces there we go and there they are
practicing a little bit of a low
grooming
so definitely looking about see if
there's any potential prey around
hello Ben who's nine years old and Ben
all I heard is that something somebody
told me that it was possibly your
birthday unfortunately I couldn't hear
what your question was it was a bit
broken up but happy birthday Ben who's
nine years old I think Megan is saying
how fast
what's the Cheetahs maximum speed there
a document doing as much as a hundred
and ten kilometres an hour but that was
quite a long time ago now it's thought
that probably top speed is between 90
and 100 kilometres an hour so it's still
very very fast and much faster than any
people or any person could run I think
the fastest person ever recorded was
Usain Bolt and I think he's I think was
forty five-degree 45 km/h or something
like that so well more than double what
a human being can run
and we get some lovely tender moments
from the boys
now these moments of ello grooming which
it means sort of social grooming are
very important when it comes to
re-establishing the bonds that they have
while they often will fight and scrap
with each other so after those moments
of fighting and scrapping the the little
licks and loves are to reaffirm that
they are all still friends while they're
on the move which is a good thing for us
and they're moving in a good area for us
because I hopefully I'll be able to hear
Megan if I go a little bit higher oh no
you know what they're doing
cheeky cheetah they're using the shade
where one is using the shade of the
safari vehicle to sleep in there's no
trees around so if there is a convenient
Safari vehicle just death lie in that
shade I thought they were going to keep
moving hopefully they will but for the
moment they're lying in the shade of the
Safari vehicles but I'm gonna have to go
up the hill a little bit see if I can
hear Megan
okay Wow we're gonna wait to see what
these guys get up to while we do that it
seems like Noel is with something that
is a lot bigger and a lot scarier than a
cheetah made it over to chat with them
and it is a beautiful scene right now
we've got lots of hippos playing in the
water they're also enjoying this
sunshine as well as this a little bit of
a breeze
we had one hippo that was out the water
but she climbed quickly back in as we
came up so these are the youngsters that
have been giving us such great antics
that passed a few times we've been here
as they get older they get more
comfortable in their space and they get
more playful and then obviously a lot of
the play that they're doing is going to
help them later in life when they're all
grown up whether they're male or female
whether they need to defend their little
ones or defend their territories as
males so hippos have a very thin
epidermis a very thin skin and they
don't sweat like most of the mammal
species we see out here they don't sweat
and they have no hair to help protect
them from the Sun or the heat so by
staying in the in the water during the
day it makes up for all of this and also
is protecting their skin remember their
skin is very sensitive because of that
thin epidermis because of that thin top
layer of skin so a lot of the times when
you do see them out of the water they
appear quite pink and that's that very
special secretion that they make that
works like a sunscreen it's it's
basically a mucus over their skin and
they lose more water through their skin
than any other mammal which is something
that we talk about so if we were similar
to a hippo and we lost as much moisture
through our skin as they did we would
need to be in the water or in a moist
environment often or else we would
dehydrate excessively or desiccate
that's okay it's another word for
dehydration usually desiccation refers
to lizard species and snakes and things
like that but we can also use it to to
work for us as well and then of course
because of all of this that's why they
move outside the water when it's a
cooler or a night time for their feeding
practices
to mitigate all their circumstances
other animals that live in sort of drive
very very dry areas that have the
probability of possibly dehydrating will
also do a lot of their feeding at night
something like a hemlock or even spring
bulk which we don't get here but in more
arid areas they'll do something similar
and they get a lot of the moisture they
need from eating the plants during the
time of the the evening or early morning
where the dew collects now just right in
front of our car maybe two meters from
our vehicle we have a beautiful little
print and call that's sitting here in
some old elephant dung and these prayers
and calls I'm look before I moved here I
stopped printer calls every now and then
but we have these ones that nest in this
area we that really great sighting of an
egg maybe about a month or so ago and
then every time I've popped up here I
keep seeing them but I haven't seen any
chicks yet and I have a feeling that not
many of the eggs have survived because
this is where the elephants like to walk
down when they come to drink and
obviously elephants have a very big feet
and so it can sometimes be difficult for
these birds to keep their eggs alive
because remember they're not making a
nest it's just a tiny little scraping in
the ground and then putting that egg
right there and the egg is meant to
camouflage
Kevin you're curious know are there any
crocodiles here at chitwa dam there are
Crocs and I'm actually happy to look
around from our vantage point right now
to see if we can see any I'm not seeing
any from here they could possibly be in
the water or they could be up on the
island where I cannot see or buildi do
you see one on the other side there
yeah we're just taking oh there's some
bushbuck on the other side there again
an antelope species we don't see often
they like to hide in the thick bush
these ones particularly like to be
around the dam and just on the right
hand side of your screen as well there's
a spoonbill that white bird with a
spatula type bill and then it looks like
some white face whistling ducks and
maybe an Ibis that's over there other
side it's quite far away from where we
are it's on the stoop of chitwa main
lodge they're just checking the rocks
that side
Willow whose three years old hello
willow you're curious to know if hippos
talk to each other and I'm not quite
sure if you heard all that grunting that
just happened now willow they do indeed
talk to the two each other most
organisms communicate with each other in
some manner
hippos outside the water make that funny
and laughing grunts on that we just
heard a little bit of now and then they
also communicate underneath the water
they it's there related to HIPAA too -
whales hippos are related to whales
they're in the same order so all of the
organisms that we work with - whether
were human or were a bird or were a
plant or were a hippo we all have these
different sequences that we fit into and
so hippos and whales are cousins of each
other and I'm not sure if you've ever
heard whale song under the water I'm
gonna do my best to imitate but it's a
sort of
[Music]
singing noise and hippos will do that
underwater in a similar fashion there
they laugh using their their lower
jawbone they're able to communicate that
way with vibrations yes it's such a
beautiful afternoon here well though I
don't know if you're coming to us from
the States but if you are when I was a
kid there was a really wonderful program
with Ben Affleck called voyage of the
Mimi and there's some really great stuff
on humpback whales from there I didn't
know maybe you guys can google it with
your mom and I think you'd find that
super interesting so while we're busy
looking for things like crocodiles and
maybe a little husana here at the
Chitwood dam let's head on over to
Tristan and see what he's up to
well I'm busy watching a poor African
Harrier hawk will resume the gene for
any of you that remember the old name
being mobbed and chased by multiple
folktale drummers you can see the little
drongos dive-bombing this poor African
Harrier hawk and the reason why they're
doing that is because the Harrier Hawk
obviously is a bird hunter and so it
goes into the nests and goes and hunts
all of the little chicks and things like
that and so it gets disciplined very
quickly by the folktale drummers it gets
chased away and is made to get out of
the area and to try and go somewhere
else
now the reason why we know it's an
african area as you see it Bank like
that into the lights you can really get
a nice indication of its coloration it's
got that gray color with those yellow
legs and face masks which can change to
red sometimes when they're in breeding
phase and then it's got a very heavily
broad barred tail so white and black on
the tail itself which is very very cool
so it's a it's a beautiful bird to see
and we often see them around quarantine
and various other parts of the reserve
going from military to military sticking
their long legs inside those trees to
try and get into the nests and try and
find things like squirrels babies and
obviously chicks of birds and that's why
the birds get a little upset with them
and try and kind of chase them away and
send him somewhere else but that was
very good well done Davi good camera
work with it and it's not easy to follow
a soaring bird they look like they just
kind of
circling very slowly but they actually
move incredibly fast particularly when
they are being chased by other birds but
so far no luck on Tandy we've done a few
loops around I drove where James said
you sawed onion cut this morning and
while there are tracks absolutely
everywhere we haven't been able to find
anything as yet we've seen you know
where she was moving up and down the our
tracks for the middle cab this tracks
for her it looks like they might have
gone north again and into towards sort
of Rebecca's side and westwards and
maybe she's got to kill somewhere there
I'm not sure so I'm just trying to do a
few loops now towards sort of triage
down Zoe's Road just to make sure she
hasn't popped out in any of those areas
if she has well then we'll be able to
pick up tracks and follow them from
there but otherwise we'll just keep
looping around and as it gets cooler
hopefully that's going to mean she is
going to start moving and either go for
some water oh maybe just go back to a
cub or maybe back to a kill that sheep
might potentially have right well I will
be going towards treehouse a dam now in
trying to search for what I am looking
for but it seems that Taylor mccurdy has
managed to find what she was looking for
and hopefully it's a very active day
when you raced on over because I was
worried that we're gonna start running
out of time because it gets so dark so
quickly we were of course talking about
that hello little one you seem to be
very excited matching up to that female
that one's just come out of the den no I
don't think that's your mum
there is a young cub that is suckling at
the moment just hiding in the grass that
is slightly older than this the little
one that's being a bit cheeky remember
how I said this clearly one young hyena
cub that's still quite black in color
isn't probably between five and seven
weeks old somewhere around there that it
walks around like it owns the place and
I can only imagine it must be one of the
higher ranking females cubs but there's
not many adults or answer better be
careful when mom's not home to be quite
cheeky towards the other adults but the
race to them undercover at the moment
they're hiding away from
the wind that's here and I suppose it
would be quite nice and cozy down in
that borough we did also see two other
hyena closer towards the road they
actually look like males to me they
could have also just been very young
females but not too close to the den so
they're do scatter themselves aren't
like we said it was hard to swat them so
mom could be around here somewhere also
a herd of elephants I think moved
through we can still see the elephants
but we I think we would have missed the
interaction maybe about 15 20 minutes
unfortunately you can see them just off
into the distance I think they would
have come straight through this den that
would have also sent the hyenas running
and I'm sure the youngsters will be very
nervous of encountering so these large
Giants and maybe you know actually
you've got a bit of a fight and send
them down into that virus so it does
it's not particularly active at the
moment not 15 seconds you said you found
you find hyenas very interesting I did
you and that's why we spend so much time
at the den sites when we can
unfortunately they're not always active
when we want them to be like right now
at least it's a little bit of a sight of
a hyena just to get your fix of course
but there are really fascinating
creatures and and I like to spend them
at the time of them because I think
there's a whole lot that I don't know
about hyenas it goes on behind the
scenes so I always look forward and I
said pretty much with my notebook in
hand and my pen waiting and watching the
various behaviors that I that I see and
hopefully I'll start to get to know the
individuals of the north clan and and
then go from there but for now they're
very relaxed just suckling away filling
up that belly before the adults have to
search for some food again it all starts
again of course it's a big routine come
back feed the Cubs go off look for some
dinner come back to the day and
sometimes they don't come back to the
den for a you know day or two but we'll
search here for a no never mind what
I've spotted that looks like it's a
little bit more interesting is just
to the writer that hyena up on the shrub
is a white broad kook although haven't
seen lots of them at the moment
hello I've been seeing lots of juveniles
too which has been quite fascinating and
we saw that the other morning and I'd
said she had never seen juvenile white
pride crew calls before not alarming at
the hyenas I would imagine that this one
lives within the vicinity and sees them
often now bird would not necessarily be
on a hyenas menu and even though there
are very very good hunters we don't
typically see them going after the avian
species however to a young leopard or a
lion cub of course they would be quite
entertaining I can't say that I've ever
seen young hyenas sort of chasing around
birds like we see with leopards and
lions for example or no never seen that
before
I don't think that there's any need for
them to be chasing after after those
characters just yeah listening to the
elephant's feed not as well as few
little sis tequilas and things shouting
I'm not sure what they're shouting about
I don't think it would necessarily be
the hyenas now Dave be wondering if I
you know would ever hunt alone but
possibly if males out on his own or
these two Cubs they I didn't even see
them they're so camouflage and I've
actually never have seen hyenas hunting
and chasing kudu wrong because we used
to see that a lot done at sabi sabi the
kudu were petrified of the hyenas and I
have seen hyenas chasing kudu on
quarantine which is that big open plain
that you see down in Zuma in South
Africa but I haven't seen one on its own
before it wouldn't it wouldn't surprise
me they remember hyenas are not
necessarily always together they do
spread out all right what's happening
now girl you done suckling your cubs
they do look like they've got nice full
bellies and there is another side she
there's a sub at going towards their
kuku that's quite funny here we go look
it's actually looking at the cuckoo you
can't see it right now it's quite
camouflaged but it's still in their
truck and it wasn't really manager seen
a duck down into the left of that truck
trying are you being a bit curious about
curious here we go here's something I've
never seen before and it isn't
fitting that we were just talking about
youngsters perhaps chasing after birds
not pouncing in there like a young cat
would but just investigating just having
a little smell
I'm sure if a bird got too close maybe
they would snap it and try and catch it
and I don't I don't feel like they would
go chasing after it did there's so many
other obviously hyena Cubs that they can
play with one another they can keep
themselves entertained and I suppose
that's what's quite nice about living in
a family whether it's a clan or a pride
whereas the adults don't have that much
of a responsibility to keep their
youngsters entertained they can kind of
rely on the other youngsters in the
group to entertain one another we see
that with lions as well whereas leopards
it's a little bit different mom has got
a huge responsibility and even with
cheetah you know if it's just mom and
one cub she's got a play with him she's
gonna keep them entertained all the time
hello fluffy oh there's a few more
starting to pop art oh they so sweet I
love them when they're that age I'm
missing tima so much that was a very
sweet little hyena there we go
being quite affectionate to one another
just sort of smelling and licking
where's that bossy cub that was Archie a
moment ago I'm sure he'll come through
and stir a bit of trouble like it always
seems to do it's like the floppy eared
cub of the hyena clan right we'll stay
here for a little bit longer because it
seems as though the Cubs are starting to
emerge from the den will they come up to
the car I'm not sure however brint
is still keeping a watchful eye on the
cheetah I am but a watchful eye from a
long distance and fortunately there that
comes gremlins down in that valley are
very bad so I've just managed to put
myself in a position where we can still
keep an eye on them and it does look
like they might get moving again shortly
so and we're just sitting probably about
500 metres from them on top of a little
hill where I can yeah Miggs talk to us
so here we go there are moving now I'm
hoping that they do come up towards I
see although there's not much to eat
yeah oh and hopefully they don't cross
the lugger again because that could be
interesting for us we just managed to
get through now the main crossing at the
lager is that someone is stuck in little
crossing though so there's a whole big
traffic jam of people trying to get
towards the boys but they can't get
there because someone's got stuck in the
crossing we made our own crossing of
course but I don't want to do that
crossing more than once it was quite
hairy the first time but it does look
like there are slightly sloping upwards
towards us well towards the top they all
say let's just move around a bit okay so
it looks like there might come up
towards the handle here so I'm just
going to keep up up high for the moment
and where I can still keep an eye on
them
[Applause]
well take Oh
so it looks like there are almost sort
of heading towards there's a lone tree
over there that seems to be the
direction now there could go floppity
flop
all five seem to be up at the moment
and it looks like we might be in for
some more raining again this evening
fortunately it's still quite far away
hopefully they'll come back into a good
comms area shortly their general
direction does seem to be up towards
kissinger's or Kissinger's is quite far
away but that's the direction they're
heading towards sort of [ __ ] rock and we
will stay with them as long as possible
so we know where to look tomorrow
morning
and as you can see there are other
vehicles also enjoying the sighting and
we do apologize for having them in shot
but we have to stay quite far away for
now um hopefully they know don't sit
down no keep moving there we go good
boys
Alan is wondering about one of our
favorite cheetah and Malaika
he saw a video of her and jumping on a
safari car and wondering what are the
rules about that it's naughty Alan said
I mean if she jumped on our card
probably be will she jumps on a lot of
cars I don't let her jump on my car she
tries to jump on my car just tap the
side like this or start the car to stop
her doing that but certain people will
let let let let her do that so the
problem is is that one day there might
be a small child in that car or a very
scared person who reacts badly causing
her to react badly oh dear
did they flop down into the grass no
whoo okay guys it looks like they're
gonna run are they still two up um but
yeah so it's it's not ideal let's put it
that way
it's discouraged heavily by the the park
officials and just in case something
happens oh my goodness
his people stock oh sorry I find it
amusing and true crossings above seems
like they've managed to get out of the
one crossing while someone tried to
cross the next crossing and they've got
stuck I know I probably shouldn't laugh
at other people's discomfort but it is
quite funny
oh yeah well we get looks like they're
going flat for now we're gonna sit here
play the patience game for a little
longer while we do that let's go zooming
all the way back to South Africa with
Noel and B Kingfisher we have a
beautiful woodland Kingfisher that has
been diving into the water not for fish
but to clean itself to bathe
we're thinking for sure in general don't
eat fish they are insectivores they eat
insects and this one has just found a
beautiful little shady spot too every
now and then jump in but Billy and I
gave each other a little bit of a fright
just now we have found the crocodile and
we were busy doing a delay test so I
have to clap my hands for a delay test
so we know how far the the voiceovers
carry between us and the Mara and the
croc was right here at the edge of the
water you can just see little bubbles
sort of going away now I've got we
didn't see it it's moving away under
there alright so we don't always get a
chance to talk about fish because fish
are not always something that we see but
that since we're here at Chitwood dam
fish might be a good thing to talk about
about 40 percent of all the fish
worldwide are freshwater fish so those
are fish that we would live in here now
something interesting about South Africa
is that 25 percent of the freshwater
fish that we find in places like this
are actually not fished from South
Africa they're alien invasive species
fish like bass bass for instance is an
alien invasive species now something
like that crocodile that just gave us a
little bit of a scare and something like
the Egret that is a cross and this tiny
little bit of vegetation over there
they're going to eat fish and we have
forms of tilapia here as well as you
should find perch every now and then in
here and then there's another one that's
tickling my head it's Jack and I had the
name just now and 6kp me another alien
invasive species fish we have his carp
and a friend of mine fishes them a lot
and he always feels good about himself
sorry everyone
there's the woodland Kingfisher I'm
gonna take you away just because I can
see the crocodile now again
too busy moving underneath this little
bit of vegetation just see the top of
the head there so a large crock like
this
we'll eat mammal species like Impala but
it will very much eat larger fish as
well and you weren't asking about Crocs
I'm actually hoping that this one will
get up onto the island here it does
enjoy being up the side now a larger
croc like this let's say it got a small
to medium sized Impala it might be a
little bit big for it but let's just say
it did that that meal could last it for
a long time but let's say for for
hypothetical reasons it couldn't get
anything like that eating things like
the fish there in this dam are going to
sustain it throughout the year now a lot
of times in in southern Africa you'll
find that crocodiles east of 8 which is
a type of hibernation when wintertime is
cold and dry as opposed to cold and wet
which happens in a lot of the northern
hemisphere places and they'll dig
themselves into the banks of dams like
this or sometimes they'll go inside
termite mound that Kingfisher really
wants to be heard I hope you can the
background but sometimes you'll find
that even through the winter months
you'll still see Crocs in large dams
like this still moving about because the
food resources are still readily
available I feel like I'm competing with
this woodland Kingfisher at the moment
go ahead sir no he's done he's now
preening himself
and and so you'll get movement
throughout the year as opposed to areas
where the water will sort of disappear
during the dry season and then the croc
lowers its body temperature to almost
non-existent heart rate to almost
non-existent and and and does that
hibernation
now they'll do we might be a bit too far
away but there's a tiny little baby
hippo that's starting to come out of the
water there let's see if we can see this
baby hippo for a little bit as he comes
out you can see that pink coloration
we're talking about now he doesn't have
any playmates
playmates over there he's just playing
by himself and investigating historians
but I believe my friend Tristan has some
elephants that we've been searching for
so I think let's head on over to him and
have a look - but many elephants and
they stretched out all the way from tree
house day I'm going sort of in a wispy
direction and North South everywhere we
look there was a Lee's around and so
we've caught up with the majority of the
herd except that they are not
disappearing into the thickets of course
they would they were all out on the road
a few seconds ago and then when it's
time for them to put on the show well
they've decided no it's time for some
shade in a bit of feeding which you can
see there's old trunks sticking through
and they are ever so tentatively feeding
off one of these weeping wattles that
still has a few flowers on it so they're
trying to find some of those yellow
flowers to feed on now what I might do
is just quickly reposition ourselves so
we get a slightly better view because
most of our chilies are quite hidden so
I just want to try and kind of go round
them a little bit if rusty would decide
to go into reverse because rusty doesn't
feel like going into reverse sometimes
and so you have to kind of be a bit
rough with rusty and get rusty to
actually do what you ask it to do but
that's okay we good friends by now we've
made up off the rusty ejected me from
the vehicle and I took it through some
thickets so we now have had one for one
and we're all good and so everything is
okay now
hopefully if I can just get around this
area and position myself slightly in
front of this herd we will be able to
get them all kind of walking towards us
that's the idea anyway whether or not it
works I'm not quite sure but let's see
how we go
what they're trying to just look for a
little bit of shade for Dave and I
because it is fairly warm in the Sun and
so a little bit of shade would be
thoroughly welcomed in a day or on a day
like today should I say not in the day
that's not a very good English and James
will he's already beaten me once in
ping-pong will probably beat me again if
I carry on using English like that so
there try and sort myself out doggy I
think if we go round this bush then we
should be good then they should be
walking straight towards us from here I
can see some of them coming out and sort
of try and position ourselves like a
bitter this little gap here should be
good nice little bit of shade I think we
gonna be in a winning situation here
Dobby
there we go just try go around the bush
and that's better isn't it it's not the
best shade that I could have found this
little bit of Sun another thing Dave's
probably got more shade than I do but at
least the LE is all nice and clearly
visible and you can see that they have
had a fabulous time probably a tree out
there maybe even at the shabam or mud
wallows but they were all absolutely
covered in not only mud but in water too
so they've wherever they've been they've
had a really good bathe and it's needed
on a day like today if you're a big
large animal like an elephant you do
need a bit of water to try and kind of
cool you down as well as a bit of mud
now campus you want to know what is the
most dangerous animal to encounter in a
vehicle well you're probably looking at
it so the elephants in vehicles can be
incredibly dangerous they're animals
that possess serious amounts of power
they are able to easily turn over a
vehicle no problem and you have a
situation where they are you know
sometimes very defensive of their young
ones as well as they might have had a
fight if it's a male with another male
or they're in a condition called masked
ratures the heightened level of
testosterone and therefore they can be a
little bit temperamental and when they
decide to take you on well we're no
match for them even in a car they'll
easily be able to flip a vehicle and
then throw all the occupants ours as
well as mangle it into a piece of tin
foil basically and so in aliens by far
the most dangerous for us are chained
vehicles probably closely followed by
buffalo and hippos which sounds really
odd but so the two of them can be a
little bit feisty Buffalo not so much
because they want to attack cause but
they normally cause damage to vehicles
when being chased by lions and they
blindly panic and run particularly at
night and then they can hit quite a few
vehicles all right well we're gonna
stick to that Ellie's because there's
nothing better really I suppose maybe a
lipid with the elephants would be better
but sitting with Ellie's and enjoying
their company on a warm afternoon is a
wonderful way to spend a day it's very
relaxing and so we're gonna spend time
here and while we do that it sends you
back over to Taylor mccurdy and the
cuteness that is those little spotted
hyenas
there's no better way Tristan then to
describe the hyenas the way you've just
done I also think that there are
adorable now I can understand why people
don't think they're so precious when
they well they get older but at this age
you cannot tell me that looking after
these fluffy creatures especially the
two on the left they're very very very
cute they're just sort of staring at us
at the moment tell me that that's not
precious that is absolutely adorable and
it's getting windy and it's getting cold
now I'm surprised that they've actually
come out thank you little hyenas there
comes a naughty one just popping out of
the the den now it's two naughty ones
just sitting at the entrance there I
still don't know how many Cubs are in
this clan I think I've seen a few more
one two three four five six I'm pretty
sure we've seen a few more than this did
we count nine obtained many new Cubs the
other day I can't even remember but
perhaps between Rolf and I we can try
and figure it out and whoever else comes
to the den oh they're so sweet but being
very very quiet you've had some very
interesting sightings over the last few
weeks coming here and they've been very
busy there's been a lot of fighting
that's going on so it it is nice to see
all peace and quiet I say that and then
those two know who's starting to bite
one another I think they're fighting
over that stick that's just coming out
of the ground must be a root of a plant
or perhaps the stem of the plant both
going to chew on and it's amazing how
they didn't even acknowledge it but as
soon as one finds something it's like
kids
if give him a one toy everybody wants to
play with it fit that one that's walking
away and ones not interested I think
it's going to go bother that older cab
now joy you said that they are such
characters they most certainly are that
cuckoo has landed on the ground I wonder
if that little hyena is actually seen it
because it's marching over in that
direction let's see if that youngster is
spotted it yet and what its reaction is
going to be I don't think it's
Cina oh here we go oh look at that did
you see the hawk behavior change very
quickly here we go no we'll find out if
hyena Cubs chase birds or not I could
have been completely wrong very excited
by though he's stalking me hiding maybe
it's going to shoot out of that hole and
race towards that kugel however that
little hyena cub is not going to be
quick enough to catch that cougar I can
assure you and I think that's why that
Cukor knows that it's quite safe playing
around on the ground most of the
youngsters are out in the open where it
can see adults how you know won't be
interested in that bird no no interest
whatsoever it's just popping back out
again right well it's been a beautiful
afternoon with a hyena Cubs I think
we'll come back here first thing
tomorrow morning and hopefully spend a
bit more time with them perhaps you'll
see some more action no wells down in
South Africa as you know she hasn't got
a leopard but she's got something that
has got lots and lots of feathers and we
found a really nice view of an African
Jacana we are just trying it keeps
moving down the way here let me just see
there we go let's get a view there
gorgeous gorgeous gorgeous it's been
hunting around the edges here for
aquatic insects and also non aquatic
insects notice the large large feet to
help it through muddy areas it also
allows it to stand on top of floating
vegetation like water lilies and this
birds there it gets an aquatic insect
there and you just saw another one
floating past aquatic insects are really
interesting they need to breathe still
but they have different ways of being
able to breathe so for them to habitat
these areas that this chick oh we got
one at this jacana is fishing in they
can attain the water under water from
plants using a snorkel they can also
fill up their lungs and
they stay underwater for long periods of
time or some of them have evolved
self-contained underwater breathing
mechanisms like some spiders and some
adult insects and they trap air bubbles
over their spiracles their spiracles or
how they breathe and then mosquito
larvae are quite interesting they have
sharp spiracles to penetrate plants to
get air bubbles or they use a snorkel on
their back end that they hang upside
down in and then get water that way also
some aquatic beetles trap air underneath
their wings so all of those insects are
able to live in this habitat and then
because they can live and breathe in
this habitat something like this Jacana
is able to obtain food sources and then
its body has developed to be able to
access some of their species that other
birds wouldn't necessarily be able to do
because of the foot structure and where
it can live David you're saying this is
now number 47 on your list
fantastic I'm hoping that's 47 for 2018
that's a good list so far Tristan and I
were talking today Tristan's going on
leave soon and I asked him what he was
doing and he's good there I caught one
there
nice little aquatic insect Tristan's
gonna go birding in the Kruger National
Park and he's gonna go look for some
lifers there and I'm very jealous of the
lifer list that he's aiming for this
leave and if he gets them I'm gonna then
have to go on leave very shortly and try
and take them off as well
now jacanas are polyandrous so basically
what happens the female will come and
lay eggs and then she goes away and then
she does it with another male and then
another male and then another male and
then the males all are the ones that
take care of the chicks interestingly
enough happens in some bird species but
not many and happens in very few mammal
species if any
so I was also watching this Chicana
earlier it was picking insects off a
dead log that were non aquatic insects
but I think he's found a nice little
spot to access them at the moment
another fish
we were talk about fish earlier and I
forgot about this one another fish that
we would find in a lake like this or a
dam like this would be a barnable or a
catfish found a catfish carcass here the
other day
most likely brought up by something like
a fish eagle this Chicana won't
necessarily eat that catfish but many of
the other bird species might scavenge
off of it gorgeous absolutely fantastic
well that was a special little sighting
Bill D is very keen for some Leopard I
am also very keen for some Leopard so
we're gonna carry on and go have a look
and we're gonna head back over to
Tristan who's still with his elephants
I am indeed and they are slowly but
surely coming right pass at the front of
the car so we've got a few of them right
next to us right yeah so you can see
they very very close so I'm try not to
move too much with them but the whole
herd is just slowly but surely tracking
across the front side of the vehicle and
I was hoping that we would get them all
coming past it's a beautiful relaxed
herb at first they were a little kind of
nervous of us so we saw a situation
where there was a few years that were
out and a little bit of sort of
hesitancy from them but now they've all
relaxed quite nicely and you've got a
beautiful view of this not a huge herd
but at least a decent sized herd coming
past you can see some of the youngsters
are now filing out of the background and
the adults are still sitting feeding all
around us and you can see they don't
spend long in the Sun as soon as they
get into the Sun they start moving quite
quickly because otherwise it just gets
too warm and even though they have this
incredible ability to cool their body
down with their ears they still are
having to try and and just kind of get
out into some semblance of shade no
excuse my head there I held it in frame
I'm trying to duck down but it is very
very difficult to in his in his all
around you and so
the touch sorry Darby it was my fault
but there's I think a little baby in
amongst it yes there's the little tiny
one let's see how cute that is that's a
fairly newborn baby I would say maybe a
couple months old if that and it's a
fairly active little thing as well keeps
following everybody around all over the
place right Dave let's reposition once
again because they've now abruptly moved
past us and we've had news as well for
those of you that are wondering about
the in Coomer pride now the in chrome
applied for some reason I don't know if
James found their tracks today but
Rick's and reckons their tracks are from
during the day today have walked through
Juma and have crossed into Arethusa
chasing buffaloes I was hoping we would
be able to find them he said the tracks
were hitting in this direction so that's
why I was just sitting with these
elephants in the hope that maybe the
elephants would help me find them in one
of these blocks but it seems as though
they've crossed in terraces on the trail
of some Buffalo and so we're not going
to be able to find the inclu homers
today which is very very sad I actually
don't even know the last time I saw the
increment probably actually I do sorry I
lied the end Coomer pride the last time
I saw them was when we were in
rehearsals for TV which was at the
beginning of December and so I haven't
seen the income of pride for quite some
time and it really has been very little
time with him over the course of the
last year so be really nice if they did
decide that it would be pleasant to come
back to human not stay away as much as
they have over the last little bit right
so this should get better now Davi I'm
just gonna try get around once more so
what we're trying to do is just try and
kind of heads around their head a little
bits a ninja's Park looking their way
but just park close by and just watch
them kind of come past us in a sort of
45 degree angle that's the idea behind
this anyway whether or not it works we
shall soon find out but at least we have
a fairly nice view from where we're
sitting now you can see they're just
kind of coming broadside to us at the
moment and it is the most beautiful day
big blue skies green summery bush and
grey coast of Africa moving through it's
just one of the best ways to spend a day
look at that isn't that picturesque
it certainly is a stunning summer's day
it couldn't ask for much better and
thank goodness there's a bit of a breeze
as or because otherwise too
be stiflingly hot the Aimi's looked
fairly relaxed about life as all they
have had their mud water so they'll be
cooled down and well for them it's just
a bounty of food at the moment as they
moved through these green grasses and
these treed areas with lots of foliage
it's like a mixed salad on buffet for
them so they've kind of just moved in
and they just take whatever they want
with their trunks and they will be quite
selective about what they feed off at
this time of the year because they've
got so much to choose from they can find
the tastiest treats and so you see there
she's kicked up a small acacia tree and
those will be the tastiest leaves that
she has Archer what amazes me is that if
I had to go and pick up that tree or any
one of you you is lacerate your hands
completely but yet that infant has just
shoved that entire tree into its mouth
with no worries whatsoever and eaten it
all so it just goes to show you how hard
their palate is but they absolutely love
those occasions it's one of their
favorite things to eat in particularly
in the summer months if they've got a
few flowers on them they get these tiny
little yellow flowers that are full with
nectar and they absolutely love them and
you'll find that they'll chomp them down
the one in the back there is targeting
some Guinea grass by the looks of things
and it's got a beautiful sticky sweet
seed on it and that is also fairly tasty
if you're an elephant so lots to each
other and really good nutrition for all
of them as they kind of work their way
through the thickets from water point
towards point because I'm pretty sure
this herd is going to start heading
towards the red dam that's where the
kind of angle that they're going in at
the moment is that they'll go past human
into arethusa towards that dam and this
is how elephants grow at this time of
the year I mean it's very hot as they
literally just feed their way from one
water source to the other where they'll
top-up water and they'll then crew
themselves down and then carry on again
with the feeding process to satisfy that
massive gut system that they've got very
cool you can see how completely relaxed
they've become Nasser it started out
that they were bit kind of no there's a
vehicle in amongst us and they were
paying attention to us whereas now you
can see everybody is completely calm and
they're just doing their own thing and
that's one of the nicest things about
being out here with the Ellie's in this
particular part of the world is that
most of them are super relaxed and you
get these intimate sort of moments where
you in amongst the Emmys they're all
around you it's just the nicest thing to
do and to spend time so a perfect way to
spend a Sunday afternoon in my opinion
it's actually quite nice just listening
to them ripping up bits of grass I'm not
sure if you guys can hear it but as they
pull up Tufts you can just hear this
ripping and then the slow walking as
they kind of go through it and in the
avene I mean leaves brushing on their
skin it's a lovely sound to listen to
and that coupled by the breeze present
way to spend the afternoon
now funnily enough actually where these
elephants are standing right now just to
the right of them on the ground you'll
see a big sandy patch that's there so
that area over there Dobby now that
little patch there some of you may
remember a few months ago is where
shadow went chasing after a warthog and
she was digging around in there and as
she turned her back and walked away
and water came flying out so she's just
been a little bit more patient she might
have gotten lucky but it's amazing to
see the difference when we filmed that
there was absolutely no grass around it
and it was a fairly bare patch now it's
incredibly well hidden only just noticed
it now as the only kind of all pastured
it's exactly that spot where we had
shadow peeking for toe so amazing how
things change in the summer months but I
mean let's just repositions like Eastern
we need to try and get
into a different area once again it's
nice little gambler that picking corn is
a lovely big game path I must remember
this game part because I'm pretty sure
that's going to be a big hole but I was
going to say that these game paths are
really good for a lot of our predators
now I'm trying to see how big a game
path we've got that's okay so it's a
nice big art for pyro that is yeah so
it's difficult to see but then maybe you
can see it but basically it goes in like
this we park now on top and this will be
done by odd fox or something like a
porcupine that was a dig there and so
every now and then if you're not paying
attention too much and you're not really
looking you can end up inside one of
those and I actually had a friend of
mine that was once being chased by a
buffalo and he was running away from the
Buffalo and as he was running away he
ended up in a situation where he fell
down one of those and thank goodness he
did because if it wasn't for that the
Buffalo would have got to him and he
managed to fall down these are alcohols
right let me reposition myself and while
I do that let's go back across to
Brinkley Oh Smith and his well I think
he's left the cheetah now and is
probably racing home and trying to get
out of the way of a rather large storm
look at that look at that that is a
massive wall of dust that's being
I stopped for yes
apology to mittens and flax
you
and we're already starting to get
raindrops but that read there that is
dust
it is a monster and
we're going to be
night because the Roofus will be too
flooded to cross so I'm gonna keep
moving now Oh me Ollie's chasing
something they know the cheetah hang on
hang on hang on there's a cheetah
chasing his sheets aren't going on hang
on into a long way away I just saw the
eyeless shoots out of the bush he was in
and take off at high speed
I'm out of that foot
sweet
it's where the chief may be we're gonna
get on second cheats a kill in a day or
in the afternoon actually Oh rain go
away rain go away just wait to let me
find a cheater
she messed it looks like she missed
where am i binoculars we're not kiss my
nose my nose where are you is that here
there it definitely looks like it yeah
she must you see her you see ahead and
just hang on go back
zoom right in the center of screen there
where my finger is
she missed whatever she was chasing oh
yeah it's so much excitement right at
the end of the Safari but now I am going
to make a like a cheetah
probably not drive as fast but I'm gonna
try to get away from that storm before
it hits us and there we go Adrian's
gonna give you one last look there's a
the rainbow the wall of dust and the
massive storm behind
isn't that beautiful actually this just
take a moment stunning now I really have
to - let's go back to Tristan